[Music]
so hyoe like a married life really good
my rings starting to decompose those
none of it oh my god what was that
somebody's trying to kill you critic why
hi guys
I was just thinking of how an astrologer
critic gave a negative review of Fievel
goes west and that made me angry just
thought I'd mention it okay do you guys
realize what this means jinkies mystery
where our pick we got some work to do
danger level boys that's why it was me
okay Roger of course from the previous
Scooby Doo reviews nobody cares okay
what are you doing we had a mystery to
solve
I could have been the suspect nobody's
falling for it you couldn't even hurt a
fly that's not true look what's going on
here I mean we had a whole scooby-doo
mystery plan we even had a cute and
cuddly sidekick Oh
pah-pah-pah I know but that's not what
people want to see anymore they instead
want to see the criminal revealed as
early as possible
with little attempt to make it look like
it wasn't him yeah so too
says scooby-doo the mystery begins
[Music]
often referred to as the third
scooby-doo movie this um I was talking
oh he usually takes over at this point
but I was talking you know you tried to
kill me I'll let's place shit to you but
I was told to refer to as the third
scooby-doo movie this week will aired in
2009 on Cartoon Network hey remember
when we used to run cartoons showing how
our gang of mystery solving teenagers
met what we got I guess is on par with
the other lame scooby-doo movies but
there's a certain half-assed nature to a
lot of it that makes it feel even more
uneventful he'll half the characters
don't even look like their original
selves that is the one thing you guys
got down what the hell is that supposed
to mean I'm telling you this movie just
doesn't try as hard as the others the
other movies were awful - exactly I get
out while you still can screw you Roger
these costumes took a long time to make
and I get most of our costumes took a
long time to make and we're gonna solve
a mystery while doing this review okay
cool
by the way here's all the evidence that
perfected it let me know if you need
help figuring out who did it it was me
by the way well we're not gonna let him
or this movie ruin our mystery right I
don't know the mystery seems pretty
killed yeah I feel like the stay black
marshmallow man yeah let's just go see
if the Flintstones made another
live-action movie wait go back
Sykes and shit so let's see if this
prequel is just as bad as its other
films this is scooby-doo the mystery
begins
I warned you noted so like I said before
the film is actually a prequel to the
live-action films rather than a sequel
are we ignoring the pup named scooby-doo
mythos now it looks like everything
takes place in a town called Coolsville
but we know that's not true the only
population there is as the credits roll
shaggy it looks like is late to school
and has problems fitting in
have a nice trip shaggy yeah you should
see how the treating Peter Parker in
fact isn't that the same stock bully do
they just make him in a factory
get a neckerchief or something oh yeah
that's supposed to be Fred and this is
supposed to be Velma both looking
different from their traditional designs
you see half of them don't even have to
look like the characters anymore oh come
on a little change isn't such a big deal
when did you shave your head oh he did
that a while ago yeah people are used to
it and the different wall color that
will never forgive things don't seem to
get better when they go to school hate
this job
janitor well go ahead Fred and Velma
right down that suspect he doesn't like
working there clearly he's a suspect
it's totally believable okay that's
obviously a fake up I don't see how the
real culprit is revealed early like look
here shaggy just randomly talking with
the principal of the school and friends
mr. Rogers do you have any you know what
helped me stamp collecting I'm
particularly excited about my latest
find one-eyed Jack I'm sure this
character we just met go into great
detail about his interest and backstory
will tie into something anything
you'll notice that the Jackrabbit has
only one eye those are the most valuable
huh I'm sure all of this will have a
connection to their characters it's
totally not just gonna pop up again at
the end or there's so many ways this can
tell you two their personalities like I
said this is how it's done now come on
guys wait maybe there's another mystery
we can solve watching this like what
like how long would it take for someone
to figure out it was him just looking at
the IMDB page ah jinkies that's a good
place to start let the mystery began
actually right away
he's literally getting captured on the
homepage damn it is nothing try come on
guys let's see how they're ruining the
live-action Tom and Jerry movie this
must be problem-solving hijinks
meanwhile at an adoption fair guess
who's the pet of the day he's very
affectionate
and he'd bring a lot of joy to any
family are you kidding it that thing
looks like a way he designed Hudson home
or just eat us I give credit this scooby
looks more like the cartoon in this
version in that Eve looks
two-dimensional and poorly animated but
sometimes the people's reactions to him
were just strange like look at this
father and daughter who decide to adopt
terrible things but the dog jumping on
me and licking me there is no therapy or
Church for that Swifter realizing
Coolsville looks ironically dull scooby
escapes from his cage and goes out on
his own coming across a graveyard where
this seems to happen all right let's
play a game
what's more frightening the
intentionally scary goes rising up from
the grave or the unintentionally
frightening eyes and yogi bear's ball
sac here you have chosen this goofy runs
away from the ghost and comes across
Shaggy's house where he sneaks in
something out there got you spooked
shaggy Scooby's over there what's under
that sheet and why now scoobert new oh
yeah wonder if people call you scooby i
think anything sounds better than
scoobert sounds like someone microwaved
Burton's scooter from the Muppets it's
all levels of in Pleasant
naturally the two of them get along and
they partake in this terrifying dance
animation now let's play another game
which of these random faced cats will
haunt you till your dying day you know
yourself well picture Essen is the scuba
bomber and sneaked him onto the bus boy
I know this damn dog has been scary
enough already in this film do we really
want make him look like a slasher from a
low-budget horror film at Joyce Creek
can we see that film instead Scooby
causes trouble though resulting in the
bus losing control he'll be fine it had
just two days left to retirement who is
responsible for this clearly the driver
or them you will spend two hours in this
room every day starting at 3 o'clock
sharp got it
well we better start breakfast club or
the Power Rangers no talking no texting
and no eating even if they cut my budget
now I've got to do double duty with a
bunch of illiterate let's hear it for
the wind like thank God it wasn't the
least bit convincing but we have to give
some impression the writers were trying
some
but the room starts shaking as something
supernatural seems to be going on
[Music]
oh no oh those reading from the handbook
for the recently deceased again during a
pep rally and oh look at that
the principal happens to be there too I
wonder if a masked character is gonna
pop up soon you know it's sad when a
lifeless mascot looks more alive than
you're supposedly living animal whoever
chooses to remain here anyway the
password is Fidelio get undressed let
the orgy begin the Vice Principal blames
our heroes for this scare though because
they're right there gives me great
pleasure to inform you that you no
longer have detentions because now
you're all suspended now if you kindly
point me in the direction of something I
could go about oh yes that's very good
scooby-doo where are you oh come on you
watch the show it's not right here it's
blue that's like saying live long and
succeed in material terms or be
financially successful I know it's the
same thing but it's not the same thing
shaking invites everyone to his house to
figure out what the story is behind
these ghosts there's extra chicken soup
in the fridge thanks mom and I'm leaving
you with your favorite friend Roger he's
going back to the science lab sweet pad
check blacklight drawing a Sammy Davis
jr. even for shaggy that seems really
odd I mean it was clearly Sinatra that
coined the phrase go be do but knowing
these writers the only Rat Pack they
probably know is these guys you are not
gonna believe this
so they look up who the ghost in the pep
rally seemed to be it looks like the
loot s's are up to their old tricks
again time capsule was that it's a small
container used to preserve historical
artifacts in order to capture a certain
time like nostalgia and the various ways
you can cash in on it so they sneak back
into the school so they can examine the
scene of the crime
sheesh even the background is giving him
hints on how to write a better movie
I took the liberty of borrowing this for
investigation jinkies look at this what
is it I'm not sure and based on the fact
that this is a high school I don't know
if I want to find out but the ghost
attacked by taking over football
mannequins you know those usual football
mannequins every school has just ran out
okay to be fair I'm a woman from the
1800s I clearly don't know how to play
football
[Applause]
[Music]
why do we suddenly look like Snoopy the
dogs brass creepy stuff happens in the
dark man they're locked in the freezer
and the next day they're discovered by
the Vice Principal plainly these
paranormal culture guys aren't
pussyfooting around we'll have to call
Peter Piper and his peck of peppers for
this the vice principal asked if this
was all Shaggy's doing no it was just us
the hold on it wasn't just them I was
there too so was I yeah I'm Spartacus
well I am pleased to inform you that
your suspensions have been lifted oh
yeah you're now to be executed oh yeah
we can do that they end up getting
expelled as Shaggy tries to think of who
the other suspects could be the school
never wanted to be a janitor
oh hi guy was totally in a trash can
down the hall when he said that I got
the shining now I've got to do double
duty with a bunch of illiterate guys we
got suspects see that I got suspects
history's getting good I know everything
in the world says one thing but taking
out facts proof evidence in character
history
I really feel there's this allocation
he's clearly unbalanced individuals get
to there's a mystery here I'm good on
Scooby dooby doo where well that one was
easy I didn't even need to say a line
come on guys let's insert live-action
hanna-barbera joke here so hyper is that
your real name
it's a way
of life
[Applause]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
so the gang wants to interview the
suspects but can't be seen at the school
so they all work on disguises the
Scoobies just eat a fly like a frog you
guys have done episodes with the Harlem
Globetrotters kiss and Don Knotts how
are you finding new ways to make this
more insane
they're apparently impressed though
without Daphne made-over Velma
[Music]
congratulations you're attractive to a
dog achievement unlocked Fred goes as a
cool as ice poster Daphne goes as the
chick from Blair Witch 2 and I'm not
gonna lie I did chuckle when I saw
Shaggy and Scooby going as trash cans
pull your pants up droopy drawers droopy
drawers isn't the name of Scooby's
cousin or something or am I thinking of
the porno version I find not knowing the
answer to either so they spy on the two
suspects and find the librarian is clean
and the janitors
I'm possibly gonna kill someone but
hasn't yet so they now suspect the vice
principal because of course that's the
next probable choice velma can you find
out where he lives he lives on top of
coolest old mountain it take us all
night to ride our bikes up there
teachers don't get paid shit how the
hell is he living at the top of a
mountain unless he's in the hut waiting
to light the beacons of Gondor i don't
see how this is possible
shaky reveals he can drive them up there
because he has a license and is older
than he looks because he was held back
[Music]
well that was unnecessary dive into
Scooby's thought process with no more
fitting conclusion be something like
this so they go to find a car from
Daphne's extremely rich family right
behind you
we can kidnap a ton of kids with that
300,000 miles that's a mystery this
machine still runs cool hey did you also
know that the Ghostbuster logo came from
a graffiti artist in the subway nobody
cares is it weird that all I'm thinking
about is what that you used was toy
cameo front and center is thinking oh my
god oh my god oh my god the scene is
shit it goes on and on forever how did
this don't get greenlit they drive to
the vice principal's house where they
have some friendly conversations in the
car it's just since we started this
investigation so many my theories have
been disproved like the theory that I'm
attracted to boys you were right about
the chemical and you found the name no
no not about that stuff about you never
forget back to my last joke they make it
to the vice principal's house where they
split up and search for clues
you know I hear scoopy offset does an
amazing Julius Caesar his rendition of
Ren's run treeman Remy arrears sent
shivers down the New York Times critic
but you know does the fart stuff to pay
the bills rough the ghost appeared to be
waiting for them and hi
why are you going in plays your ghost
that's enough it's like if Freddy
Krueger went into the soul of a fly boy
I'm a boy bitch I'm a goddamn boy wow
you really do suck at this so it looks
like they solve the mystery of who did
it time capsule it's gotta be what he's
after
we did it we solved the mystery and with
way minutes to spare anyone want to play
clue I bet we'll all suck at it but go
scare them outside though where they
fall into a trap he guesses them and
takes them to the high school where he
forces them to find the capsule or he'll
kill Scooby you'll never get away with
his vice principal Grimes yes because
those two clearly have the same build of
one another
Peter Dinklage was my next guess shaggy
what are you doing hanging myself I want
out of this film who uses my dog and I
do anything to save them they'll head
down to find the capsule where we come
across a very strange big moment are you
okay never better
has anyone anywhere ever shipped Velma
and Fred was that in high demand I'm
gonna take a wild guess and say Scooby
and Shaggy you have more slash art than
these two it doesn't go anywhere anyway
as they trick the villain into coming
down I think we found it the problem is
it's really heavy well all right where
is it well come on let me have it
I insist that you let me have it and I
mean that in a completely on ironic way
I get the book from him and try undoing
the spells but that only releases more
ghosts and funny enough they forgot to
write in how this affects our heroes as
the ghost never makes their way towards
them they just go after random people I
mean what are we supposed to say here oh
no that lady won't be able to microwave
her lasagna it's like saying I need to
find a spell to get rid of these
monsters each kibble is compelled oh now
it seems there's monsters in Australia
actually some of these ghosts may get a
little too friendly I'm just assuming he
was tying her shoe they finally say the
spell to send all that goes back but our
main villain is still there it's pretty
damn good timing if even one thing got
delayed this scene would be like you've
got to change us anything would be a lot
shorter Skippy escapes and saves the day
though leading them to discover really
the only person left and there's still
some how surprised by it
principal deal you ruined everything
this doesn't make any sense really this
doesn't make sense
I mean okay this guy dressing up it's a
ghost to give time carefully at the real
world yeah I'm sure but I did it in
scooby-doo really of course he reveals
what we already knew that the rare stamp
he was talking about in the beginning
was in the time capsule and this was all
a ploy to get it I feel like there could
have been several ways to accomplish
this not including raising the dead but
he says the thing it would have been all
mine if it weren't for you meddling kids
and your dog are people not seeing mangy
anymore I love me too you bring back
mangy the students are praised for their
work and given a celebration in their
honor it was a combination of Fred's
leadership Velma's brains
Daphne's resourcefulness I am the most
important ingredient of all pot our
friendship no no it's definitely pot I
can't believe it we solved an actual
mystery actually you didn't you had the
wrong suspect the whole time until you
um asked him you escaped death by blind
luck but that doesn't look
good on the side of a man shaggy however
takes some of the dog treats he made
earlier and decides to give them a name
would you do it for a Scooby Snack
yeah I figure you love these treats so
much I named him after you
somehow I'll manufacture them and get no
credit but at least we have an
incredibly wacky origin story now we end
with tons of scenes either recreating
the cartoon or we wish we're in the film
we saw and the movie finally ends it's
really amazing how much of this does and
yet somehow doesn't connect to the
cartoon I guess just like the other
scooby-doo movies when you really think
about it so critic now do you see why
you didn't try as hard on this one I
don't know Roger maybe we can solve the
mystery of why you didn't try it yeah
it's pretty obvious the movie is bad but
it's bad in a different way from the
other Scooby films those movies were at
least creative and how awful and
unfocused they were this one is just
kind of bland and generic on the one
hand it makes sense it's a kids TV movie
with a much lower budget but it's
instantly forgettable the acting is fine
for the most part in the effect for a
kid's film I guess are passable but in a
weird way it's even more infuriating
that you can't get that angry at it at
least the other two were spectacular ly
bad this one is just unimpressive ly bad
I don't know if you want to take that as
a compliment or an insult but still a
Scooby turd
I suggest passing up so I guess if we're
not gonna do a mystery we might as well
put the costumes back you know we're
looking forward to doing something with
oh yeah Roger still a psycho well well
show and you're dead okay well there's
only one thing to do in this situation
Netflix and chill
[Music]
what was it oh that happens whenever
somebody dies around here you should
really get some rate for that oh let's
see who this dinosaur really is
let's see who this really is Rob let's
see who this Rob really is Oh Rob let me
go oh man oh man
dinosaur came full-circle kind of guys
what are we doing
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
you
hey Doug Walker here doing the charity
shot on this week we are doing City of
Hope founded in 1913 city of Hope is a
leading research and treatment center
for cancer diabetes and other
life-threatening diseases designated as
a Comprehensive Cancer Center the
highest honor bestowed by the National
Cancer Institute and a founding member
of the National Comprehensive Cancer
Network City of Hope's research and
treatment protocols advance care
throughout the nation every discovery
they make and new treatment they develop
gives patients the chance to live longer
better and more fully their
patient-centered philosophy guides
everything that they do their
researchers advance ideas into
discoveries physicians bring emerging
therapies to patients and students learn
to transform the landscape of modern
medicine if you look at their site in
their YouTube channel you'll see that
every day they pursue new and better
ways to improve the lives of millions of
people around the world click on the
link and see why for many city of Hope
is where hope begins
you
[Music]